Let's go.
Just because a lot of people are interested
in this arc.
Let's go to our friend Pedro from Colombia.
Of course, none of us believe that that's
the case.
But what's new?
What do you have for me this week, Pedro?
All of Mr. Foxman, thank you for taking my
call.
For The Voice.
Oh, really?
I just really wanted to tell you, you know.
You know, thank you for the show and I appreciate,
you know, all the people on, you know, all
the people, all the viewers who are telling
me, you know, you're not nice things.
You know, I have your meeting.
Oh, yes.
You know, I just want to tell you, you know,
you're a good guy, Mr. Parkman.
And I actually did send you a picture of me,
by the way.
I don't know if you bought it.
Yeah.
Pedro sent me a drawing of a stereotypical
Mexican mariachi guy, which is a weird thing
to send if you claim to be from the South
American country of Colombia.
Right.
That's an unusual thing to send, right?
All you know, all I want to do is send an
actual picture of me, but my wife, you know,
she well, she doesn't like that I call the
show at all, you know.
I see.
And, you know, she got mad when I told her
I'd see my go up there and our union came
during a meeting.
Now, that's a.
As you and your wife, of course, immigrated
to the U.S. from Colombia.
Right.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
And you do speak to her in English.
That sounds unusual.
Oh, no, no, no.
Well, we talk in between Spanish and English.
You know, I'm just doing a little impression
of her.
So how you can actually say when how does
your wife tell you in Spanish that she doesn't
like you calling the show?
What does she say?
I tell you, I'm on my way back when I time
you talk like you're not interested here.
Now it's kind of it's kind of so I didn't
want to get on her blog, so, you know.
Yeah, I just got my friend from Argentina.
He drew that little picture.
But it's not just like me.
It's not a stereotype.
It's just what I look like.
Because Colombia doesn't really have the Mexican
mariachi stuff.
You know, it's not part of the culture there.
Oh, yes.
Not only the little.
No more Mexican, I love Mexicans, I love Mexico
and I love Argentina and Ecuador in Pennsylvania.
Okay.
Can you just tell me where you actually from?
Well, I'm in Texas now, you know.
I don't know.
Were you born?
Where were you born?
I don't know.
Colombia?
Yeah.
I forget I forget the theory another some
confusion.
I'll get around.
Wrong.
There is confusion.
You can just.
All right, Peter.
Listen, how long is this going to go on for?
All in all, I'll call you and say hi sometime.
You know, I don't want to bother you.
I like I like your show.
I liked your good answers and good gas, you
know?
You know, I don't want to bother you.
So you don't want to talk to me anymore?
No.
I would love to know where you're really from.
That's what I would love to know.
Okay, now remember someday.
All right.
Okay, Pedro, thank you for the call very much.
Appreciate hearing from bather.
A lot of people in the audience all wrapped
up in the entire Pedro arc as it as it may
be.